Uh, we're taking calls at (617) 830-4750.
Why don't we go next to our caller from the
three one four area code.
Who's calling today from three one four.
Hi David.
My name's Josh.
I'm from Saint Louis.
Hey Josh.
What's going on?
Hey, I'm mo long time listener, first time
caller.
And um, I actually became more politically
aware just like a few years ago as 2016 election
and I was very more conservative on a lot
of stuff because my family was conservative.
But once I actually started reading and learning
more, I kind of cross that line and I started
to become more liberal and then just more
progressive.
Interesting.
So, yeah.
And so anyway, um,
well Josh, before you want to add, I mean
I'm curious, was there any particular issue
where you realized, wow, what the rightest
selling on this issue is just totally wrong
and this, and it was like a big catalyst for
getting you to revise your political beliefs?
Well, one of the things was I'd never really
realized the hypocrisy.
I just kinda like I was raised by my grandparents
and they're very pretty conservative and I
just kind of took what they said, you know,
at face value and I'm like, okay, these are
morals.
And then my household was also very religious
growing up.
And so I just like, okay, I took this and
it was really the, uh, I guess I realized
the hypocrisy at the pro life pro choice thing.
Cause my grandfather is very ease anti-big
government.
And then I heard an argument from years ago,
I think on the young Turks it was, you know,
hey, like having the government come in and
tell you, hey, you want to, you want to control
what a woman does that the big government
like, okay, that is, and I took it to my grandpa
and then he was kind of hypocritical on it
and I realize okay.
And I started noticing all the trends of hypocrisy.
Interesting.
Okay.
They're not principled in their ideology.
Got It.
Got It, got it.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So my question to you is you, you know, you
kind of dedicate, you know, your career is,
you know, political commentary.
Like you're in it like all the time.
And so, you know, me, I find myself getting
very fatigued, you know, it's hard, uh, just
kind of talking to people constantly about
it.
And then it's just like the, my, my issue
is that, you know, I'm around so many people
that are more right wing and then so, so much
of my energy just get strained.
You know, like you, someone like you, like
how do you, you know, how do you find the
energy to just keep doing it?
Pushing on and on, you know, and just being,
you know, so deep into it.
Well listen, I mean number one I would suggest
finding some left wing people to be around.
Um, I don't know.
And you know, Saint Louis is a big enough
city that there are probably like a drinking
liberally or some local Democrats group or
something.
Like, I would definitely try to spend time
around people where you don't even, it's not
to talk politics, there's not to talk left
wing politics necessarily, but it's just to
know that you're around people who are like
you in terms of ideology because it is fatiguing
to constantly be around people that you know,
fundamentally have a worldview.
And, and even in some cases, like a moral
code that seemed so antithetical to what you
believe.
So in my, in my like personal life, there's
very few conservative people around me.
That's the reality.
And I think that that's a really good thing.
And I basically don't talk about politics
outside of the show.
So my strategy is on the weekends as much
as possible, I stay off social media and don't
do any tweeting or thinking about politics
to the extent that I can.
Um, in my sort of like day to day life, I'm
mostly around people who more or less share
my ideology and I don't talk about politics
with them.
I'm just around people who share my values
and ideology.
And those are the two things that I would
suggest you try to do.
And I think in Saint Louis it's more than
possible.
All right.
Thanks man.
All right, great to hear from you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Uh, let's take a quick break, but don't hang
up if you're holding because I will get back
to the phones which are jammed jam task.
A quick break back after this